hello Conan O'Brien here with another
clueless gamer today we're gonna be
playing WWE's 2k14 joining me once again
is Erin Blair hello fired from the show
two years ago still hangs around what's
up WWE 2k14 just came out very exciting
we've never done a wrestling fighting
game no we haven't I don't remember
doing I'm very excited is that is that
playing the national anthem yes get up
you were gonna sit there through the
national anthem so now you can pick your
gut so they have all the wrestlers there
Triple H I've met a lot of these guys
I've interviewed them over the years
titus O'Neil this looks like louis c.k
cross with Bart Simpson I've met Sheamus
yeah but on the show yes I'm gonna be
Sheamus cuz he's Irish like me and I
love that he's made no attempt to get a
tan can you make this anthem stop I love
my country but this loop is killing me
well actually we can't pay for an ending
you sick in the game so we're playing
this on a loop because it's the only
music we can afford perfect I could have
guessed that by the stools that were
sitting on and the room where were
shootings is the same room where Joe
Pesci was shot in a Goodfellas okay
you're Kane alright so now cool thing is
every Brussels has their own entrance
talking to the ring with each evil step
that's not great writing you can't take
an evil step okay is that his lawyer
who's that guy who's there there comes
my guy
if you bring women's Bikini Bottom
Brewery Wittering
he's just been to the dermatologist he's
been cleared those are not cancerous
freckles the controls are a little
complicated you walk around with this
stick this kind of stick I was way the
sticky Walker all right then you can
grapple you can grab on to be with
either A or B no kind of red or green
yep you know that I'm going to just
randomly hit buttons we've been doing
this for like two years and I just
randomly twenty bucks if you want to
reverse them it's right trigger if you
reverse what reverse an attack oh I
thought you meant take away my decision
to review this game I'll be getting that
button right now my guys just gonna walk
back and forth a little bit tell you
that we're just checking each other out
doesn't look like he's just gone insane
look I look like a person you see in the
subway he's just kind of santim driving
and nothing but look at this yeah yeah
there you go you know what I just
realized he has the Catholic cross on
his ass I'm like I just saw that you had
chicken oh nice oops
you know why some of his punching things
at random ever just hit pause hit
buttons right I am quick yeah that's
good yeah what am I doing here we're
having an orgasm
yeah it's the breaking point you want to
be my submission it was your rhotic did
you notice it look at one of the great
things about this game is you can design
your own character I've been hard at
work at mine and that's me like skin
color is correct and look at look at
just absolute existential despair that's
me I'm ready to go okay look I love the
rocks expression is sort of what are you
gonna do about it - why are we on this
planet that's up the ante but we're
gonna play Inferno match what's Inferno
match Brno is there's fire involved and
you have to roll the guy into the fire
okay
thirty sixty pounds
now the rock says like you smelt the
rock is cooking what would your guys say
do you smell that
that's my pants I'm afraid here I come
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ]
I'm surprised I'm not shot right
look the rock looks pretty scared a fire
time all 102 pounds of meat a lot of
realistic this game is wait a minute how
do you not get burned must have some
kind of Samoan oil sleep well rock now I
roll you enjoy the flames oh oh this is
the most in elegant way to kill someone
roll them in the fire enjoy the fiery
flames as I roll you
[Applause]
how would you review this okay
WWE's 2k14 I thought the graphics were
very good yeah I think this is a really
terrific game if and only if you can get
the Conan it's a great fighter yeah this
and you look at that face and you really
want to beat the crap out of it it makes
it very satisfying okay here's my review
if a bad game was worth this and if a
good game was worth this I would give
this game
[Music]
which is pretty good
[Applause]